there is a Christian pastor warning of a
Jew coup to remove Donald Trump and I
must tell you I'm surprised it took this
long to become a storyline and I'll
explain that in a second so I know that
very often when we talk about
anti-semitism on the show we end up kind
of taking heat from the left and the
right the right will often just respond
to stories about anti-semitism with
anti-semitism often directed at me
proving my point
sadly there are some on the Left who
when I talk about anti-semitism will
minimize it they'll say you know Jews
aren't really discriminated against
sometimes they even fall into the same
thinly-veiled anti-semitic tropes that
exist across the political spectrum but
I have to talk about it because this is
a real problem that we have on our hands
Europe is increasingly riddled with
anti-semitism horrible situation
recently on a London subway you can look
that up if you're curious lots of
stories to tell not for today though
Trump even though his daughter Ivanka
converted to Judaism and his son-in-law
Jared Kushner is Jewish Trump has still
hugely coalesced and catalyzed white
nationalism and anti-semitism they've
said it to me I've spoken to people like
Richard Spencer who explained it to me
the latest report from the
anti-defamation league about
anti-semitism is horrible we even saw
Republicans on the House Intelligence
Committee including their lead counsel
Steve castor play off of the
anti-semitic trope of dual loyalty to
try to discredit impeachment witness
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
his family are Jewish immigrants from
Europe and during the impeachment
inquiry hearings in November Republicans
tried to play up this anti-semitic trope
of dual loyalty and it was quite frankly
inevitable that eventually there would
be a faction that turns the entire
movement to hold Trump accountable for
the things he has done into an
anti-semitic trope or conspiracy theory
and now we are seeing the idea of that
movement the entire movement to get rid
of Trump to hold him accountable to
impeach him it is now being chalked up
as a Jewish conspiracy by more and more
people and again I'm shocked that took
this
long because when you step back from it
there are just too many overlaps between
the ways that the right has defended
Trump and common anti-semitic tropes the
deep state cabal of people working to
control the public facing instruments of
power like the presidency they think
that's what impeachment is and they
often say that that's what Jews do
there's a lot of overlap there there are
too many Jews involved in the
impeachment hearings Adam Schiff is
Jewish that Democratic counsel Daniel
Goldman is Jewish it's the Jews once
again so it was obvious that it was only
a matter of time until this happened and
now our old buddy I'm not being serious
about that Christian pastor Rick wiles a
truly sick individual is saying that
impeachment is an attempted coup coup I
can't possibly say it like he says it so
take a listen that's the way the Jews
work they're just they are deceivers
they plot they lie they do whatever they
have to do to accomplish their political
agenda this impeach Trump movement is a
jew coup and the american people better
wake up to it really fast because this
thing is moving now towards a vote in
the house and then a trial in the senate
we could have a trial by before
christmas this country could be in civil
war a christmas time that's right a jew
coup there it is and you know the thing
is there has been whacked-out
anti-semitic christian pastors for a
long time that's not news worthy in and
of itself what's different today is that
they are more emboldened than ever by
donald trump and not only is there a
risk of real world violence they are
pushing it here's rick wiles moments
later starting to talk about you know
the military members of the military are
going to have to pick a side here either
with the jew coup or against the Jew
coup members of the US military are
going to have to take a stand just like
they did in the 1860s with the civil war
they're gonna have to decide are you
fighting for the
earth or the south members of the
government are going to have to take
aside instead of north south is going to
be left or right people are going to be
forced possibly by this Christmas to
take a stand because of this Jew coup in
the United States we have weeks to stop
it that's why I'm speaking out that's
why I'm putting everything on the line
say this is a coup led by Jews to
overthrow the constitutionally elected
president of the United States and it's
beyond removing Donald Trump it's
removing you and me Wow really
courageous a wacky evangelical Christian
pastor blames the Jews for something
we've never seen that before really I
admire his courage in taking a stand on
that so we're seeing a very disturbing
combination here of right-wing
nationalism anti-semitism and Christian
nationalism and what's worst about all
of this is that we want to be careful
not to participate in the escalation of
violence we don't want any violence we
want Trump removed by people voting them
out or if a constitutionally enshrined
impeachment process removes Trump then
okay we don't want violence they are
both the people saying there might be
violence and the people who would do it
and the people who are starting to
allude to physical violence to resist
any kind of outcome that leads to Donald
Trump being out of the White House so we
then end up in a position where I find
it necessary to remember we shouldn't be
violent like that we can't be violent
like them they do by the way though
these evangelical I hate to even call
them churches so-called your churches
they need to lose their tax-exempt
status this is political advocacy which
violates the tenets of those non
non-profit statuses that are given to
these evangelical groups and churches
they need to stop spreading racism they
need to stop spreading nationalism and
anti-semitism but by predicting violence
they are also likely to cause violence
because fundamentally it's what they
it's a sick reality that we're dealing
with right now but again I'm surprised
it took this long for the anti-semitism
to overlap with the movement to hold
Trump accountable it's happening now we
are seeing it we will have more coverage
of this on the shows Instagram page make
sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show and while you're there
follow me on instagram as well at david
pakman today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that i use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listen to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
Escom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month that's be Li NK is
t.com /pa k mas